you mentioned in in an interview that
when reading a program you can tell when
the author of the program changed oh
okay
how the heck can you do that like what
makes a distinct style for a programmer
do you think
you know there's different uh hemingway
has a style of writing
versus james joyce or something
well those are pretty yeah those are
pretty easy to imitate but but it's the
same with music and whatever you can
i i i i found uh
well during the pandemic i
spent a lot more time playing the piano
and i i found something that i'd had
i i had it right when i was taking
lessons uh
you know
before i was a teenager and uh
it was
yankee doodle
uh played in the style of
you know and and
i you had you had you had beethoven and
you had wc and chopin and you know and
the last one was gershwin
and
i played over and over again i thought
it was so brilliant because but but it
was so easy
but also to appreciate how
this uh this
author mario somebody or other had
had been able to uh reverse engineer
the styles of of those components so but
now
specifically uh to your question i mean
there would be
there it was
it was pretty obvious in this program i
was reading it was it was a compiler uh
and it had been written by a team
at at carnegie mellon
and uh i have no idea
which program
was responsible for but but it you would
get to a part where the guy would just
not know how to
how to move things between registers
very efficiently and so
and so everything that
that could be done in one instruction
would take three or something like that
that would be a pretty obvious uh
change in style but there were but then
there were also you know flashes of
brilliance where you could do in one
instruction normally i used two because
because you knew enough about the way
the machine worked that you could that
that you could accomplish two goals in
one step
so it was mostly the the brilliance of
the concept more than the
uh semicolons and uh or the the you know
the use of short sentences versus long
sentences like that so you would see the
idea in the code and you could see the
the different style of thinking
expression right it wasn't yeah so it
was stylistic
i mean like i could identify authors by
their
by the amount of technical aptitude they
had but not by
styling the sense of
rhythm or something like that
you